I'm John Foley from reuters
Breakingviews I just rested the session
asking whether Asia and hind end off
energy to fuel its rapid growth and the
answer for most of municipal schools yes
although it's not by clear exactly how
that's going to happen the rich people
agreed that nuclear is going to get to
stay but they also agreed that no one
wanted in their backyards it had some
great ideas on how to help communities
and consumers conserve energy become
more efficient including an iPad app
that will show you how much energy you
are using the day to day basis and tell
you its which of your air-conditioned we
also had some slightly less usual ideas
like giving everyone abacuses instead of
computers and sabotaging the power
networks to show what if you conduct
that justice and each other like it's
great great I think we cannot with a
very strong feeling that people are
confident that it will find the energy
to meet its record word from your guest
plan future